[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
barry spurluga
he is covering the olympics he was at
the event covering for the washington
post and kind enough to join us on short
notice
what was it like when uh you saw her
walk off
barry i mean a little staggering i mean
at first of course you think
well she twisted an ankle or she's
getting a knee treated and
and can't she go on and what's her
physical state and um
and then you know word kind of spreads
around that it wasn't in fact an injury
that
um she's making a decision based on
mental health and i i gotta say dan like
you know this is something that's come
up in the lead-up to these olympics it's
come up
uh at these olympics um simone manuel a
swimmer
talked about it at trial she was a gold
medalist in 2016 and didn't even make
the
team here in that event it is naomi
osaka's story here
um so if you put it in the context of
these athletes
you know they only are relevant to
mainstream american
sports fans once every four years you
add a fifth year onto that
files is trying to cement her place as
the unquestioned
you know all-time great in her sport
i think you're right you heard it in her
voice there is a toll of all of that
and do we have answers to everything yet
and like
the individual events like it it just
feels like there's a there's a great
mystery still to be solved here barry
oh for sure and and she addressed that
the the
all-around competition for individuals
is on
uh thursday and of course she she won
that in rio she's the
huge enormous favorite here um
but she said tonight she's she's taking
it day by day they're gonna have
a morning off with no practice tomorrow
she sounds like a woman who needs a
morning off with no practice tomorrow
um she's gonna clear her head um and you
know this opens up all sorts of stuff
where you know what if she competes for
the all-around gold as an individual on
on thursday night did she give up on her
team
in essentially doing those same things
um on
on a tuesday night um it'll be really
fascinating to see
really interesting to hear what the
reactions are
from other athletes but i think
what we're looking at is a changing
athlete a changing
viewpoint of of what these people endure
in you know being in the spotlight and
then
training and going through the grind of
it out of the spotlight
um they're being much more frank about
about how that affects them
and you start to understand the enormity
of this that yes it's pushed an extra
year
and nbc and peacock have leaned on her
and katie ledecky to really be there's
no usain bolt there's no michael phelps
that
they're leaning on these two athletes to
carry
the next two weeks and i don't know what
that
pressure would be like the enormity i
can only imagine that and you're
supposed to win gold
you know covering the olympics the
beauty is a 17 year old from alaska who
wins a gold
and that's the great story of the
olympics simone biles wins gold
or a few golds be like okay
we expected her to and and i think you
could almost you could hear that
pressure
and that and boy that says a lot about
what she must be under right now
and that's that's the dichotomy of it
right like the 17 year old lydia
jacoby from alaska like no one if she
had
won bronze we wouldn't be talking about
her
she would be enormously satisfied her
hometown would be
thrilled um but it's an extra layer
because
she came out of nowhere she she won that
gold and she didn't have to think about
the stuff that
simone biles thought about not just this
morning when she was getting up to
compete
but when she was flying over here and a
year ago when the games were postponed
and when she was evaluating does she
want to continue and
should she just retire um those are
real pressures and people can say like
well
she gets the spoils too she gets the
endorsements and she's gonna make
millions of dollars and
and that's all true but i think we
should be mature enough
and and developed enough to acknowledge
that
you know millions of dollars don't
instantly make your head right
um so it really was an amazing
sight to see her walk off
come back and legitimately root on her
um teammates but also say on this day
given my mental state i would have been
a hindrance to the us
winning a medal not a help well there's
collateral damage i mean michael phelps
talked about this
looked like he had everything and then
you realized that
he understood that he he was damaged in
some way
and that's the greatest olympian that
we've ever seen that that enormity
and he's the one i think who was ahead
of the curve on this stuff he dealt with
it
in the middle of his career and kind of
pulled himself back to get to rio and
and win more um so if somebody who has
won
23 gold medals more than anybody in
history
is saying you got to listen to these
athletes and and
telling athletes you have to tend to
yourselves
um i think that's really important and i
would say too
and this is such this is why it's such a
layered discussion it's like
you you have to acknowledge that being a
champion
athlete takes some measure of mental
strength and we we can't just say
all of a sudden okay we've the standards
are completely different
you know but there is what is fighting
through that and persevering
and what is tending to yourself so you
don't break down i think that's
over the next three years to the next
summer games that's
that's probably the discussion that
needs to happen not just
around athletes but but with athletes
barry thanks for joining us we
appreciate your time thanks a lot dan
barry sverluga he is covering the
olympics joining us from tokyo for the
washington post